there's a bunch of games now available
that was compatibility like stuff that
was on the 360 so does like meet boys on
its mass effects on us yeah geometry
wars oh cool one of the few 360 games
you would still want to play yeah as
available and yeah but actually both of
you piñatas our partner that part of the
preview is that yeah that's in there and
soak a banjo kazooie Xin the silica got
a rare stuffed presumably that rare pack
they're bringing a rare replay yeah well
if you think about it like the the thing
that there's business involved with
selling these things or putting these
things up on Xbox one its mobile
business so it makes sense for a lot of
the stuff to be kind of Microsoft and
stuff where developers don't necessarily
have a reason to say no yeah and mass
effect might be a good idea to like you
know get all those xbox one fans
interested in possibly on drama die when
it comes out in a couple of years yeah
maybe I don't know that seemed like
that's the one that is now I mean it's
still in preview like they're saying
it's gonna be one to one and like online
compatible with existing like real xbox
360 hardware but it sounds like right
now stuff like mass effect isn't running
quite as well and well in some cases
runs better I don't know if you do that
but we do like a video comparison we
sort of saw some screen tearing there in
the the xbox 360 version they've like
lower the frame rate but implemented
vsync it seems like to get rid of that
so it's maybe not better graphics but a
better experience sure I guess I'm one
of the games will get into what we sort
of want from that program in a bit but
one of the games that I know you want
that has just been an answer will be
coming attitude is burning of paradise
yeah so so was there an update because I
know there was a criterion got it there
and said like we're talking to Microsoft
more news soon okay is that it no yeah
that's it okay so presumably so you know
we talked to Microsoft a couple of times
during e3 about this stuff and they've
made it pretty clear that it's a
business thing like they're emulating
the 360 on the Xbox one period like full
compatibility no you know they like no
shim that has to sit between the game
and the hardware that's like game
specific stuff which you know and for a
lot of pc based emulators there's a lot
of really crazy game specific hacks that
go on on some of the more advanced
systems when they're kind of saying that
this isn't that that this is going to
work across the board and it really is
just a matter
of a publisher or rights paper saying
yes yeah so the idea that criterion is
talking to Microsoft about it like no
criterion would talk to the rest of ya
or something and say like just say yes
yeah like that's that's how Microsoft
pitched it so I'm not really sure what
that means except that maybe since it's
still a preview program thing like
they're just not done emulating that
yeah so maybe there's some conversation
to be had there it's weird with a game
like that because paradise is like an
online enabled game so presumably they
need to keep all those servers open yeah
yeah there will be like Xbox Live
compatibility you're even gonna have the
xbox 360 dashboard when you hit the home
button in the xbox one controller it
like straight beeps at 36 back and you
hit back and started that can start sure
yeah oh really the guide pops up yeah
yeah so and as for games that haven't
been announced yet Microsoft have a
kelipah up like a website you can vote
on for like your favor wish list of
games yeah and it makes for interesting
reading I took the top tragic 30 tragic
or maybe ya at the top went up there at
the moment is a black ops 2 followed by
red dead redemption I'll support that
that's a good shed at Skyrim I got ya I
got a surprise that there was no Skyrim
xbox one ps4 announced already like HD
real and maybe maybe there will because
it's honest yeah modern warfare 2 halo
reach black ops gears 343 cod for mass
effect 3 modern warfare 3 he says it new
new Vegas I think called duty world at
war left 4 dead 2 gears of war two so
mostly shooters six of the top 13 are
call of duty games that's ridiculous
it's not so depressing like the idea
that like there's this annualized
franchise that like people I get one or
some of that speaks to like the the way
call the duties falling off for the past
few years I think but you know like
people want black ops 2 that's kind of
the high-water mark yeah the idea that
like people were like man they need to
bring back modern warfare 3 yeah no
world also they won't write like the
it's the the big thing Microsoft did by
kind of getting out there and saying
that it's it's like up to the publishers
is like disavow all responsibility and
go hey it's on them it's a business
thing it's on them so whenever you
complain about like hey I'd really like
to play my old call of duty games
like you could play to Activision not
Microsoft yeah and it's like smart in a
weird way but I got if I were Activision
I would never flag any of my games for
backwards compatibility cuz why would
they just they don't make money off the
youth sales of those games they could
put them up you know there they are up
for a digital download like you could
but like you're not there's no
additional money coming in to do that
yeah they're trying to push people to
the next call you could be countable
izing your own Marcus yeah asa Khalil
yeah they'd be better off you know like
you know they'd be more likely to say
like hey we're putting out call of duty
classic it's all these multiplayer maps
yeah in one big downloadable thing buy
it all over again I feel like the one
exception is like arcade games and
downloadable titles so if we can still
monetize that so I can totally see the
incentive there and that's again the
same thing they have to negotiate that
with the license holder right that's
weird with someone like they say super
meat boy which is actually getting like
a ps4 release I played it at e3 but the
ird own it on 360 so I've like zero
impetus to like to buy it on xbox one
now right well why am i exactly why
would you though then and they that's a
case where like the work is done so why
would they put out an xbox one version
of Super Meat Boy if they could just
make the 360 version available for sale
to xbox one owners that's something like
they you know they need to overhaul
their store their overhauling the entire
interface as well later this year so you
know it's not a 1080 60 Jeff come on but
it's isn't it though it's just a scalar
it's just a sailor speaking of games
than that haven't been announced yet
Peter I asked you to think of a couple
maybe you'd like to see on the system
yeah coming over to the Xbox one I don't
have an xbox one all right but if I did
I would do you know stake in the driver
no no but like I really like fighting
games I love street fighter xbox one is
not getting street fighter 5 ever in
shape or form ps4 just got ultra street
fighter 4 ported to it there's no xbox
one version and they were talking about
it when they announced it about seat
league last August but it's not there so
ultra street fighter 4 i think is the
one game that i would really say like
really deserves to sort of be in that
backwards compatibility this because
there is no street fighter right now on
xbox one and that may be the only
solution in the near future yeah yeah
that's a good call for sure I was
wondering if say happy action theater
would make its way over with the
nekked stuff like will those connect me
leo really yeah oh man that work was too
hard okay yeah translating that stuff
yeah exactly jeffers anyone's a stick
out to you Bobby Ryan act 0 you go
through this site like all the the user
vote stuff this you as a user voice
right let's yeah they use it for a lot
of feedback mechanisms not just this and
the you start to dig deeper and deeper
yeah that list where it's like they're
like 47 people that said yeah Bomberman
Tour de France 2011 yeah absolutely i
think i think it should be everything I
mean you know like it's there there
aren't really a ton of games that I
necessarily need to go back to I
couldn't the exception of burnout
paradise mmm which by the way was on the
fifth page yeah on that list so it was
not in the top no yeah four pages of
requested keeping voting like Oh God
finds environment right yeah they got
time with her hands they're not playing
advanced Porthos yeah I think it's just
one of those things like if it's
technically feasible they should just do
it yeah and and I actually think it's
kind of cool like you see stuff like you
know and maybe you'll see more of this
like the idea of the the old game as
pre-order bonus rights or something like
that where like you know if you get
fallout 4 on the Xbox one you don't give
you fallout 3 and you know that that
will almost obviously definitely be that
360 version yeah I'm gonna do any custom
work there and then was a rainbow six
vegas comes with e something yeah one
and two I think yeah both of them comes
with CJ see ya so I think that's like a
cool idea like they've got all this
stuff laying around yeah that you know
maybe people haven't played and you know
why not just get it out there in
different capacities and so I actually
they're selling burnout paradise on 360
as a download right now for three
dollars and seventy four cents really so
I anticipating that this deal might
eventually get done and the burnout
paradise might be playable even though
I've got it on disk somewhere like you
know what screw it like I just wanted to
show up in my game list straightaway so
I went ahead and bought that that
version of the game too yeah anything
that you know and it's it's not gonna be
every publisher
that's in the situation we're like oh
they might take the server's down
because EA were the only people that
were jerks enough to like work that into
their deals yeah where they could
disable the servers for their games and
now it's just like every a game is
Dethklok yeah my chrome hounds servers
down I can't play chrome strip yeah they
were happy I'm full of other games I
definitely fall into that alright so we
won't see chrome hands tell me the the
most dire for this yeah sure yeah that's
killer well in the meantime I guess
Gobert go by burnout paradise point it's
it was that include big surf island uh I
don't think that includes the dlc is
what everybody wants inversion yeah
they'll get you on big surf on twenty
dollars no I think about Gators I don't
know how much was but yeah you know you
go by the fake DeLorean back the future
car all right all the other stuff they
sold for that thing to get your motor
bikes yeah what happened and you know
you don't need the dlc for you don't
need the bikes that's a big surf island
you don't mixer filings not that great i
know like it should have been yeah
anyway you don't need any way there you
go right there burnet revenge burn burn
a crash even getting some votes there
look at that yeah that's it deck well
get more in log in you leave a comment
say big surf island as well yeah so go
ahead vote yourself on xbox feedback
there if you want reenact 0 or failing
it happen no don't start that konami
hudson whoever owns that stuff these
days 50,000 to only 47 742 more
bomberman act 0 things votes to make
tower reality at Jeff thanks so much for
coming on hey